transcurre aquí en Francia el octavo día
de huelgas de recolectores de basura
consecuencia alrededor de seis mil
toneladas de desechos permanecen sin
recoger solamente en las calles de la
ciudad luz porque en otras urbes del
país están también afectadas
adicionalmente hay Tres plantas de
incineración de desechos cercanas a
París cerradas o bloqueadas en un
comunicado el sindicato que organiza
esta acción de protesta Indicó que tanto
los recolectores de basura Como los
conductores de sus vehículos se ven
afectados por la reforma de pensiones de
Manuel macron incluso incluso ejerciendo
una labor peligrosa como la suya verán
sus jubilaciones atrasadas dos años cómo
reaccionan los franceses una parte
rechaza este movimiento porque con una
semana de basura acumulada que en
algunos barrios bloquea el tránsito
vehicular y peatonal comienzan a
proliferar a proliferar los roedores y
los insectos evidentemente con
potenciales consecuencias para la salud
otras personas se solidarizan con ellos
porque están mucho más expuestos ex
puestos a enfermedades que otras
personas y por supuesto les afectará más
esta reforma de pensiones importante un
dato que ofrecía la cgt uno de los
sindicatos que organiza esta
manifestación su esperanza de vida las
de los recolectores de basura es entre
12 y 17 años menor que la de otros
empleados justificada o no la protesta
pues lo cierto es que los bultos de
basura llevan una semana en París y
forman parte de su paisaje